4 3 2 1 chasse aux œufs
à peine le top départ de la chasse aux
œufs lancés à Maurepas les enfants c'est
par pinent dans le bois de Nogent à la
recherche de milliers de coloris le 2 et
là il faut que tu cherches le rouge
numéro 4 allez allez allez go
la stratégie pour les tout-petits c'est
simplement des œufs de différentes
couleurs pour les plus grands après
derrière jusqu'à la 11 ans en fin contre
c'est des œufs de différentes couleurs
mais avec des chiffres qui se suivent
deux œufs en or et un en argent ont
aussi été cachés pour plus de chocolat
chacun à sa technique pour les
trouveras
des trucs comme ça en général
on pousse et ce qui est en dessous pour
retrouver la collecte est ensuite
échangée avec de vraies gourmandises
ouais franchement c'était sympa les
petits œufs à la place il y a des petits
des grands très sympa il y a des œufs en
chocolat monstrueux je pense que là il
va falloir quelques jours pour pouvoir
les déguster et des belles panières des
belles compositions en fin de compte de
nos partenaires un rendez-vous important
pour les morts pasiens pour cette
septième édition près de 300 petits et
grands explorateurs ont répondu présent
c'est une manière d'occuper les enfants
une mauvaise manière de se lever tôt
alors qu'on pouvait se reposer
moi quand j'étais petit c'est dommage
mais j'en fais depuis qu'on a des
petits-enfants oui c'est super ça fait
la deuxième année qu'on a un œuf en or
donc c'est bien sinon puis c'est sympa
ça rien du tout moi pas c'est sympa les
cloches n'ont pas encore sonné et
pourtant les enfants ont déjà été gâtés
un échauffement avant que le lapin de
Pâques ne passe dans leur jardin et dans
d'autres communes